hey guys it is monday the 23rd of
November I'm just and here's what
mattered in gaming to them while the
xbox one's backwards compatibility
feature for xbox 360 games is getting
everybody excited it is leaving of
thinking about original xbox games which
Marcus often said nothing's impossible
on the inner circle podcast xbox is my
kubera explain we're not looking at
original xbox games on xbox one yet
right now the focus was making more xbox
360 games work it would be certainly
very challenging getting xbox 360 games
to work was incredibly challenging and
really a multi-year engineering
investment going all the way back to the
original certainly would challenge the
team that said Gabara did add that the
team mccain on new challenges and he'd
probably love to take a shot at making
it work he also said there'll be a high
frequency of new xbox 360 backwards
compatible games on the horizon brick
and mortar retailer gamestop are
reporting that their game sales are down
on this ten percent this year with some
major recent titles underperforming halo
5 guardians Assassin's Creed syndicate
and the star wars battlefront were among
the games that the retailer called out
for selling below expectations during an
earnings call gamestop president Tony
Bartel attributed this to a significant
rise in digital sales among other
factors on the subjective battlefront
Bartel said we had high expectations had
diminished somewhat as it got closer and
it failed to hit those lowered
expectations although it's anticipated
that battlefront sales will pick up
again when the movie comes out releases
which did reach gamestop sales
expectations included a fool at four and
call duty black ops 3 finally Benjamin
Burnley the frontman for the American
rock band breaking benjamin has formally
referred to star wars battlefront as
quote a piece of [ __ ] the vocalist
posted a picture of a broken battlefront
xbox one disc to his Instagram account
with the captions they wanted to pay me
to post that I like this piece of [ __ ]
game he added that the game sucks and
that he'd rather watch
prequels and play one more second of
battlefront burnley appears to be the
latest in a series of high-profile faces
enlisted to promote the game Anna
Kendrick recently said in a live-action
battlefront commercial and has also been
tweeting about the game we move down in
that comment section where your take is
on this whole battlefront a battle you
can add a game start we've got stories
on cheap steam machines and Just Cause 3
pc 6 that is everything I wanted to tell
you about David do let me know what
mattered to you and I will catch you
again tomorrow